welcome back uh we're going to start  with a little bit of breaking news  that's just come in uh  to us wayne cousins former police  officer  uh convicted of the murder rape and  kidnap of sarah everard  who went missing marketing executive who  went missing in  march has been dismissed with immediate  effect following the  conclusion of an accelerated misconduct  hearing from the metropolitan police he  was attached  to the mets parliamentary and diplomatic  protection command  and it was deemed that he breached the  standards of professional behavior  and was dismissed without notice he  pleaded guilty  uh to the murder rape and kidnap of  sarah everard  and he's currently being held in belmosh  prison